there's five ways to
um like make money and assist in any
system there's like five roles and you
can decide which one you're gonna be in
so like uh one is the logistics and
labor so like let's take a house uh
you're building a house the guy who's
actually literally laying the bricks and
out there sweating in the Heat and
building the actual home sort of gets
like paid the least but does the worst
does the most work right does the
hardest work and does the most work in
the process right he's the logistics and
labor he's actually moving the bricks
around and you could choose to do that
you could choose to be kind of a worker
bee who's moving the bricks but you're
going to work the hardest and you're
going to capture the least and life
feels kind of unfair it's unfair that
you know the real estate developer
sitting in his second vacation home is
going to make more off that house than
the guy sweating outside every day but
that's the reality that's how it goes
yeah so there's Logistics and labor
that's the lowest level of the pyramid
Next Level optimization
[Music]
foreign
Happy Thanksgiving everybody we got an
episode for you you know a little break
from the family never hurts uh this is a
dope episode I really like this one we
talked about a bunch of things so we
talked about the uh the lurking giant of
an industry that is fan fiction that's
right fan fiction uh we talked about
Vice businesses and a billion dollar
company that's serving marijuana
businesses and
um a Arbitrage around the new Kia car
logo which is pretty funny and then Sam
what else we got we talked about a very
uh famous billionaire who recently said
that 50 million dollars is about the cut
off to where any more money won't make
you happy we talk about our opinions of
that and then we also reference a few of
the people who said their opinion on
what their number is we talked about a
billionaire who's only 39 years old who
you've probably not heard of he's built
a payments company which is kind of
interesting but even more interesting
he's built the world's largest uh
training company to train Pilots
incredibly fascinating guy it's a good
episode I think you're gonna dig it
check it out
let's jump in we have some topics uh Sam
you have a topic and then I got a I got
a bunch I've got a bunch too if you
store down you'll see the rest okay but
first a lighthearted topic I tweeted
this thing up the other day chamath uh
was on Lex Friedman's podcast and there
was one three-minute topic that didn't
really get enough Justice that was very
interesting Lex goes hey so you're this
billionaire now can you explain how life
has changed being rich and he said
basically there's if it's zero to a
hundred of different levels I've tried
it all I've gone from zero to a hundred
and back I've done all the stuff and
money doesn't change stuff after a
certain point and I think that point is
50 million dollars and I thought that
that was uh and he referenced the study
he I actually can't find the study that
he referenced but he said like you know
I read this ivy league thing and I don't
know if it's true but they said that
after 50 million nothing changes because
that's plenty of uh plenty of money to
have homes all your loved ones are
handled you don't have to work you could
think about what's really important
and I actually thought that that was a
really interesting answer because
without having any evidence other than
just friends and family I think that
number is about right uh but no one ever
discusses this they always say that
stupid 70 000 a year study which is just
absolutely nonsense I don't believe that
to be true at all uh but I thought it
was a really interesting thing and I
tweeted it that like you know that's
what he said and Jason calcanus who's
chamat's buddy and also uh I imagine
quite wealthy he says uh I don't think
he's totally off but I think a couple
million in America in 2022 and you're
good 10 million that's Fu 25 plus you're
dangerous anything above that who cares
and so I want to know what do you think
do you have levels like that
my biggest takeaway is that I should
just be referencing studies that don't
exist all the time dude like the thing
you just said that is you know there was
a Harvard study can't remember what year
but totally backs up the point I want to
make so I'm gonna make this up now dude
I could not find a study and none of my
Twitter followers could I tweeted this
out too almost 200 000 people not one
person said they could find it that's
why he's a black belt in and
I'm trying to get my black belted
bullshitting and now I I learned a move
that I didn't didn't have in my bag uh
the the fake fake study reference
um you know there's these two scientists
out of Penn who
um it's really interesting what they did
so okay that was my first takeaway my
second takeaway is
um I don't know if the number's 50 I
think it's like complete like
um it's completely context dependent
somebody said this uh somebody tweeted
this out in the crypto World they go
would you rather have just uh had a
hundred thousand dollars and still have
a hundred thousand dollars or have
gotten really lucky during the crypto
Bull Run turned 100 000 into 100 million
and now it's all come crashing back down
with FTX and all this other stuff and
you're back at a hundred thousand would
you rather like have the emotional
stability of of the of one year of just
staying where you're at or would you
rather have tasted the highest highs and
now crash back down to earth of course
not the second one no that that second
one was horrible that you know lost
aversion I I care more about losing than
I do gaining that's crazy so you would
rather just stay at the 100k
well so like objectively you're at the
same level right and so you'd rather
have never never flown so high and then
crashed I think it would it would I
would I would have a life of regret
that's insane Ben what about you what do
you think
um I I think there's some street cred
that comes with having been Rich that
makes it easier to make the money back
so I would rather have been rich and and
now not be so I did this in poker I used
to play online poker pretty uh like
aggressively back in the day and
generally yeah pretty generally like you
know it's like why pay for college when
you can go lose money in online poker
instead of going to class like you know
those seem to be my strategy and so but
I did have some runs and sometimes I
would go from the 10 cent 25 cent table
which is like you know the very low
blinds up to Dollar two dollar up to two
four up to three six five ten ten twenty
and if you're at the 10 20 basically
like on any given hand you know twenty
thirty thousand dollars could be
swinging you know left and right so you
were going on these massive swings for
like a 19 year old at the time
um but then inevitably because I would
not manage my bankroll properly I would
go crashing right back down and I'd be
like well I can't afford those tables
anymore I have to go back and play the
you know 10 25 or the you know two four
Cent or whatever like the lowest Stakes
that were offered on Full Tilt at the
time with PokerStars and um and it was
the worst feeling when you had to go
back it was because it wasn't the worst
feeling like there wasn't the regret
like the regret is obviously a part of
it but the worst feeling is that it's
just really hard to get excited about
winning 20 bucks when you that same
thing could have been 20 000 and you've
tasted 20 000 at that point and so just
rewiring your brain to like go back be
humbled and be humble enough to play low
stakes again was really really tough but
really important and um but I did learn
one thing which is that once you taste
higher Stakes it does like break your
frame and so the only reason I would say
I would rather have gone up and down
even though emotionally and mentally
it's harder is the value in having your
frame broken and thinking bigger and
thinking differently and not limiting
yourself in some way that you previously
thought was a some limit for you is
actually incredibly valuable so even
though yes you're back at a hundred
thousand you have one new valuable asset
which is you think of yourself
differently and you think of the world
differently and you think of what's
possible differently than you did it had
that never happened
I don't know man I think that that is
pretty convincing
I I think that I think the argument of
like you frame breaking is good I well
what you're saying is that there's a
lesson to be learned and that you're
going to be left off better than you
then you arrive it's not just the money
yeah I think that that is
that that is almost a fair argument but
I would say that you're going to be
broken from the journey down more than
you are happy baby we got therapy on one
side and then we got things
I'll repeat the same thing I've said all
the time which is I don't think that
your opinion is relevant here because
you are this rare thing called being
emotionally healthy for most individuals
I do not think that this would help them
I think it would hurt them more than it
would help them
maybe maybe I don't know
um maybe so so but you did ask a
question about the number so you said
50. and I think 50 Probably sounds
appealing to you sounds appealing to
anybody who's got less than 50
um but then there's a whole bunch of
people who are there and they you know
they continue on and I don't know what
they would say you know I'm not at 50
million and like kind of net worth so I
don't know uh if that's the right number
or not what my experience tells me is
that it's about triple what you got
whatever you got triple what you got
feels like the number where ah I could
finally it'll finally be good and then
again I think it's always double
actually you know this is actually two
and three x this actually is a real
thing I don't know if the study is
legitimate but I did read like a thing
where they sampled like 10 000 people
and consistently the number was actually
double people said I want double what I
have uh you know if you're worth a
million they're like you know if I had
like two I would feel better it was
almost always double so I'm so you're on
to something I'm thinking about what
project I'm going to do next year so
2023 I'm I'm plotting I'm scheming it's
like pinky in the brain but I'm both
Pinky and the Brain and every night I
think to myself what am I going to do
next year and that's I actually don't
say the same thing we do every year try
to take over the world that's not
actually what I'm trying to do this year
has a different frame and it comes from
a quote I heard I think uh I think maybe
Naval had said it somewhere and he said
um
he goes
you are retired when you stop
sacrificing today for some future
tomorrow
um basically when the day in and of
itself is complete at that point you
have retired and it's not about to me
it's not about retirement but that's
also like just replace the word
retirement with winning uh like the
ultimate form of winning to me is when
the thing you do in and of itself is the
reward you're not doing it for some
maybe future speculative hopefully
reward that will come right like what
most people do is they take some they do
something that's a sacrifice in order to
have the thing they want later and they
think the sacrifice leads to the thing I
want and then there's a but what are
like the pillars for you you know I I or
the columns you know if you're in Excel
like you like content creation you may
be like investing like where what are
your what are your columns labeled well
I'll give at first when I heard this
quote I was like was that even possible
or is everything just feel like you know
hard work and sacrifice until it pays
off I was like no actually the podcast
is the only thing in my life that feels
this way the podcast is the only you
know it's not even a business but I
guess it is technically a business now
but it's the only project I've ever
worked on where the act of doing it is
the reward like I am you know like
um when it's a normal startup I'm like
what are the growth numbers what are the
what are we trending week over week
what's the revenue how can we grow this
growth let's grow the scripts all I
would think about with a normal business
and with this I don't and it's not
because I don't want this to grow no of
course I want it to grow it's because
um like the reward for me Isn't if this
grows then a good thing will happen the
reward is I love sitting down here
shooting the with you having a
bunch of topics and then like you know
the the sort of reaction to the Pod that
comes like immediately after it gets
dropped and other people get to listen
to it and so like doing the Pod is the
reward not if the Pod gets big then
there's all these rewards to be had and
that's why when I look back I say man
it's always been really hard for me to
stick with projects you know this you've
told me this like a thousand times like
stop pivoting do whatever you know like
the average lifespan of my projects is
like one year or less
um or I have to hire somebody to take my
role and I basically check out the
podcast is I've been doing we've been
doing this what three years now and like
I feel like we just got started I could
do this another 30 years I feel zero
fatigue in this whereas anything else
three years in I'd be looking for the uh
the exit path and so that to me was a
really strong signal that hey projects
like that do exist and then it's a frame
breaker right oh if that exists then I
want that out of my next project now to
answer your question about the pillars I
think the most important one for me is I
like uh High creativity things not I
like create I like creativity not
optimization meaning I'm not a good
operator who likes to optimize the the
engine every day come tweak it make it
one percent better every single day I
love when people do that but I
personally don't get a lot of Joy doing
that I love creativity
um like basically making stuff whether
it's content or it's a product or it's a
business idea whatever it is so I'm like
how do I make it where it's creativity
based
um
and I kind of had this like big Epiphany
during that process uh that like I
haven't really fleshed out but I'm gonna
I'll share it with you I wanna hear what
you think about this so
I realized there's like
there's five ways to
um like make money and assist in any
system there's like five roles and you
can decide which one you're gonna be in
so like uh one is the logistics and
labor so like let's take a house uh
you're building a house the guy who's
actually literally laying the bricks and
out there sweating in the Heat and
building the actual home sort of gets
like paid the least but does the worst
it does the most work right does the
hardest work and does the most work in
the process right he's the logistics and
labor he's actually moving the bricks
around and you could choose to do that
you could choose to be kind of a worker
bee who's moving the bricks but you're
going to work the hardest and you're
going to capture the least and life
feels kind of unfair it's unfair that
you know the real estate developer
sitting in his second vacation home is
gonna make more off that house than the
guy sweating outside every day but
that's the reality that's how it goes
yeah so there's Logistics and labor
that's the lowest level of the pyramid
Next Level optimization that's the
person that goes into any business and
is trying to make it incrementally
better increase sales increase decrease
costs this is usually a manager of some
kind and so optimization make things
more efficient make things grow a little
more you could choose to be a great
manager you'll capture more value than
the laborer but not by much
then comes performance that's kind of
what this podcast is we get on we push
record and we perform and we get paid
more than you know whoever does our
podcast editing gets paid because we
have to perform and it's like the the
result of our performance is going to be
it'll be a complete flop or a complete
hit based on how well we perform you are
a performer okay so that's like the
third level
then there's creativity that's coming up
with the concept you know creating
original things creating whether it's
content whether it's code whether it's
the original idea
um
creativity is like that that next layer
and then the highest layer is like one
who makes the most and does the least
amount of like you know laborious work
is Warren Buffett who sits in a room
plays bridge for you know four hours a
day reads and it will go sometimes years
without making an investment but when he
does make an investment he's getting
paid all paid only on his judgment and
so he doesn't get paid on creativity
performance optimization or labor and
Logistics he gets paid purely on
judgment did he make the right call or
not and that that person you know
captures the most value in any value
chain and so I think that's the way that
that like kind of like any Enterprise
works on the ecosystem works for money
and I'm trying to decide which layer I
want to play at do I want to try to play
a judgment because I think logistic is
the best but it's not the most fun to me
I think creativity is the one that's the
most fun for me or performance one of
those two do you think that you'll build
a company or do you think that you'll
build like uh you'll just get more
famous and make money off that somehow
probably not either of them uh right now
neither feel Appia feeling so I don't
think I'll create a company because I've
done that like for the last I don't know
feels like almost 15 years and
um
and I'm like okay what if my brainstorm
was limited right a brainstorm is pretty
helpful when you have a creative
constraint so my creative constraint is
what if I can't operate a company
so I got to do something
and I want it to be awesome but I'm not
going to be an operator of a company so
that could mean for example you could
buy a business and place an operator you
could be an investor you could do other
things but I'm not going to create a
company that and operates that's right
do you like investing what's that do you
like investing I do like investing yeah
I don't know if I love investing but I
do like investing and um so so that's
one and then the second one you said
which is getting more famous that also
feels really lame to me even though I
kind of know it's a good thing like it's
clearly worked it's clearly paid off for
me like getting big on Twitter or
getting big on the podcast or whatever
like this has clearly helped my life in
a bunch of different ways
but it feels kind of lame now and I was
kind of saying this during the saw Hill
thing I was saying to him but I was
really kind of just projecting I guess
which is like
it's like is that it I'm just gonna be a
guy who tweets and a guy who like goes
on YouTube is like here's three hacks
that you gotta know if you want to get
big 2020 series like oh man
I can't bring myself to do that so I'm
like maybe I just also say no to that
path because feels like a lot of people
play that game and it's not one I would
have a ton of self-respect for if I won
so then that would be a big loss if I if
I achieved it and didn't even feel great
about it we should do an entire episode
uh next week or the week after on like
the decisions that you're gonna make
yeah yeah I'm starting the process now
we'll see how it goes uh do you uh no I
mean no rush do you all right let you do
one of your topics and then I'll do
another one after that all right so
check this out
um
have you ever read fan fiction like do
you read any fan fiction like with with
like is that like a thing you do what it
what is that okay that answers my
question well I I I maybe maybe I do it
but I don't know what it is fan fiction
is basically like
um imagine okay you read like it for me
I read Harry Potter Harry Potter's great
I'm done with the books
but I want more Harry Potter I love that
world I love the characters all that
stuff so then there's people who are
super fans who will just go write their
own as if they're JK Rowling
website and then you can go right I I
don't I play sports yeah exercise
my tendons and ligaments work so no I
don't do that
um Ben I'm curious just quick yes or no
do you uh do you know anything about
this world or not
a very very little amount okay so that's
kind of what I expected and I in my mind
I'm like well that's the case for
everybody like you know it seems like a
really really Niche thing but Sam I know
you know about this business Wattpad and
um
tell you some things about fan fiction
it's insane so so
there's probably all women though right
what's that it's probably almost all
women I would imagine it's 80 women I
don't know it's it's majority I don't
know if it's 80 might be 70 or 60
something like that but it's somewhere
in that range I think 70 80 is is about
right on the writer's side for sure I
don't know on the reader side but I
think it's also there so okay let me
just tell you some interesting things
two of the biggest books in the last
like 25 years started as fan fiction so
uh Twilight started as fan fiction and
then the whole Vampire series and then
50 Shades of Gray started as a fan
fiction of Twilight and 50 Shades of
Gray became that right so like these
were best-selling books became billion
dollar box office movies on top of that
for the Twilight series and um that's
insane okay so then now you go to
Wattpad and you you look up the traffic
for Wattpad and you're gonna see that
Wattpad gets almost 200 million visitors
a month
has almost 100 million registered users
you should explain what Wattpad is
Wattpad is basically a website where you
can go and you can write fan fiction and
upload it or you can read it right so
it's the same way like YouTube you can
go and upload a video or you can watch
videos Wattpad is that for people
writing kind of like fiction basically
um and they sold uh about a year ago for
about 600 million dollars in cash yeah
they sold to a Korean company called
Naver for for 600 million and you I
remember you told me something about
them way back in the day I think you
knew the founders or our friends I
remember you and everybody uh so we were
talking you guys both had met these
Founders you had something interesting
to say I don't know if you're feel free
to say whatever your Christians were
then no I don't know what you're talking
about okay or maybe it was you maybe it
was our friend um but they were like
yeah I've met the founders and like this
business is actually crazy it gets a
crazy amount of traffic it's super like
under monetized right now and um yeah
just like I met them and they're super
cool like they love their Community but
like they're never gonna make it like in
terms of like building it into a
business like it could be a juggernaut
giving them of traffic it has and I
found this to be true for for them and
as I was looking at the traffic I saw
they were ranked number two in the books
and literature categories I was like
what's number one what could be bigger
200 million visits a month that's more
than
like Wall Street Journal New York Times
Like that's more than like for sure huge
websites and so
um I'm like what's number one and it's
this website called Archive of Our Own
you ever even heard of this no this one
I'm looking all this up as you talk 300
to 400 million visitors a month Archive
of Our Own and it looks like like a
Craigslist D type of website it's like
basically like a Wiki
um like it's like a website with no
images you know what I mean it's like a
if a library was like a website
it would look like this and that was the
intention so basically
I was like this is really big and it got
me thinking about fan fiction it's not
gonna be thinking about this whole the
all these genres right like
um and I started connecting all these
dots it's like I remember when I moved
to San Francisco there's a street in San
Francisco that they call billionaires
row and on Billionaire's row you got you
know a bunch of tech tycoons who you
know are billionaires at the biggest and
baddest House of them all belongs to
Danielle Steele Danielle Steel and then
I was like wrote like hundreds and
hundreds of basically is it like erotic
or romance related not just romance
novels yeah one of the best-selling
authors of all time out you know has a
bigger house than you know founders of
of you know what's his name David sacks
yeah like all these huge companies and
so then you and I'm like Daniel Steele
that sounds really I remember when I was
growing up my mom probably read like 50
of these books like my mom loved
Danielle Steel she used to read all
these books like maybe this John maybe
this little niche is like bigger than I
thought so I was thinking a little more
about it so there's some crazy stuff so
so one of the backstory of this Archive
of Our Own because where the hell did
this come from and basically what
happened was there was this in 2007
there's a website that get started
called fan limb and they're like we're
gonna fan Fiction's a great Niche we're
gonna build like an awesome website make
a bunch of money it's gonna be great and
a bunch of dudes building this company
and all the users were women and they
were like at some point the women were
like it's kind of annoying the way this
business is running and that all these
men are like trying to like monetize our
work our hard work of like our attention
on the reader side and our writing on
the writer side so in 2009 one of the
writers is called Naomi woman named
Naomi she writes a blog post that says
we need an archive of of One's Own and
that was playing off this thing a room
of one Zone by Virginia Woolf it's
basically this idea that writers need
space time resources to create and she's
like we just need our own not this fan
lifting and so a bunch of volunteers
create Archive of Our Own and that's
this thing that now does 300 to 400
million visits a month it's a non-profit
and they run entirely off donations like
Wikipedia so they've raised basically
350 000 in donations there's 700
volunteers that run this thing and it
just covers the burn rate of the actual
like bandwidth to run the site basically
and yeah you could look up the
nonprofits called organization of
transformative works and they're you
could look up all non-profit sales it's
only like eight hundred thousand dollars
a year and what's interesting is this
their logo says Archive of Our Own
launched in 2007 but it says Archive of
Our Own beta it's still in the beta
and so and so this uh and like the top
fandoms like so what what it what is it
what do you do so it's like you're a
fandom of some world or characters or
whatever and then people write their own
remix of that story they'll take the
Liberty to like write their own and so
you have the top ones are Marvel
Sherlock Harry Potter Supernatural those
are the top ones and um it's it's just
kind of crazy and so um like for example
the original Lord of the Rings is like
the trilogy plus the next two books was
like a total of 750 000 words 750k
a fan has written uh like a fan fiction
version of Lord of the Rings like the
extension and it's over five million
words it's like seven times longer that
somebody's just written for free right
there's like extreme passion and you
know better than anyone like these are
like red hot signals for where you're
like oh my God like you can make so much
money if you're a greedy Pig like us
you're like oh there's a bunch of energy
and passion and enthusiasm but probably
some broken tools or like under invested
in infrastructure can I go in and build
something right that's like a general
question and um I just got fascinated by
the space and it's pretty cool what
they're doing so like Wattpad basically
after Twilight Fifty Shades of Gray
became big hits they
um
two things started happening one the
publisher started scouting Wattpad like
crazy so like you know Anna Todd was on
Wattpad she's like a scout for for Simon
and Schuster or whatever and offered
like a six-figure deal to uh you know a
writer on there to basically like option
their their like blog posts basically
into a book and a potential movie and
they created their own Studios division
um and they're making millions of
dollars adapting these fan fiction Works
into into you know uh actual actual
movies from here and they say oh we got
this data like the the guy from neighbor
he's like we have this data like not
only can we see what's popular let's
turn that into a movie but we can say we
know exactly where they're reading and
where they're skipping where they're
dropping off we can say chapter one and
two are great chapter three after
paragraph two they you know people are
falling off and five six and seven you
know are good but you know need to trim
them and um you know they have like
hundreds of thousands of comments and
they could basically take all that data
and try to do a good job with it that's
the that's the pitch at least I found
fascinating what do you think I'll give
you two data points that I I think show
you're you're on to something the first
one which I brought up is the website
lit lit erotica have I told you about
that
uh this was your home page right what is
what is this
yeah right uh lit how do you spell it
it's uh it's like literature and erotic
yeah so lit around.com okay I'm there
okay so it's the same thing it's this
like ugly looking website that looks
like it's you know uh built in in the
the 90s basically uh what's the traffic
for similar web say that it has so this
tells me 60 million visits a month
you know website it's a plain text
website and so it's another example of
just these like uh basically lit erotica
I think that's how you say it
literotica.com
oh there's some lit erotica man yeah
it's it's similar but it's basically
like User submitted stories most of them
sex based it gets crazy amounts of
traffic and it's I think it's only run
by one or two people but now that's
another example of one of these like
low-key websites that crushes it which
is like a nice proof of concept but the
second uh proof of concept that actually
is a wonderful company is have you heard
of fandom
yeah fandom's like a like a Wikipedia
basically for all the different stories
right yes uh so basically any TV show
that you care about particularly if it's
like animated or a cartoon or something
but even if it's not like you go there
and it'll like give you a list of
episodes a list of characters and things
like that and I think they have a fan
fiction section but what I didn't
realize was uh it was started by Jimmy
Wales the founder of Wikipedia right and
he's actually I think uh as of recently
was still the president of the company
he sold it the the company was sold and
it now does over 200 million dollars a
year in revenue and is incredibly
profitable it's owned by uh the churning
group I believe uh is that tpg tpg so
this is a different one
um so that's just the PE firm yeah one
of the things yeah so it's owned by like
like one of the biggest PE firms in the
world and they kill it so I believe that
you are absolutely like on onto
something spotting like an interesting
Trend yeah and so I don't know where the
opportunity is yet I haven't like sort
of done the kind of full exercise of
like okay what what's the play here are
you
um taking it to mobile are you doing
some sort of subscription thing and
we've talked to in the past about the
idea you had prototyped I don't know if
you want to should we tell that again or
or you think that's covered enough
wait wait I'll I'll in 30 seconds which
is basically uh my friend and I uh had
this idea where we could create like an
audible but for erotic stories and we
created this really simple website what
was it called it was called short but
romantic and we drove like uh 500 of the
Facebook traffic to it we got someone to
write a story on Fiverr we got someone
to narrate it on Fiverr and we got like
500 in subscription Revenue overnight or
over a weekend and I don't think what
happened did we we we told we talked
about in the Pod and then a person went
and started a newsletter that was this
but only specifically for black women
and he ended up selling that business I
think after six or seven months for like
six figures right yeah I think that's
what he said uh I I don't know we don't
know too much about it so I can't say if
it's if it was for real or not but yeah
definitely uh definitely a super
interesting Niche that's like
underserved I think not most I think
it's under most entrepreneurs and most
kind of like programmers are not really
thinking about this stuff uh but there's
a lot of attention I mean fandom gets
700 million visits a month like is it
kind of insane right like it's insane
these are kind of mind-boggling numbers
so
um yeah I think that's kind of crazy can
I tell you another
um slightly like kind of Niche almost
like
um like Vice type business have you ever
heard of a company called duchy
no so if you just Google duchy's try
duchy.com does that is that like a weed
thing yeah it's a weed thing so they're
basically what they did was they created
a like a point of sale system for
um
for dispensaries and so what duchy does
they I they basically they took like the
same model of like square or
um you know stripe in a way but mostly I
think Square because they have like sort
of the in-person like card reader type
thing and they're like look these guys
like dispensaries are underserved it's
getting legalized in more places and the
big companies are never really gonna go
here because it's like too much you know
hair on the on it for them they have too
much to lose and so wow these guys are
huge though they're huge they they're
basically a multi-billion dollar company
I think they were valued at one or two
billion dollars I think three three
billion dollars and they they say they
have like 30 or 40 market share which is
like kind of in a crazy saturation
800 or 600 million dollars yeah so
really really impressive uh and a fairly
short amount of time I don't know when
it was launched exactly but it is uh
it's not like you know
yeah 2017. so like you know five years
and uh three billion dollars later and
um and we've talked about this before
like you know we one of the early ideas
I got a lot of traction on the Pod was
stripe for vice which is basically like
taking payments is a pain in the ass if
you're doing anything that is that gets
blocked by banks by Visa by you know
MasterCard whatever and um the companies
that end up serving you know
marijuana porn uh these different
Industries those companies uh you know
end up picking up a lot of adoption very
very quickly and can become very very
valuable in a very short amount of time
dude this is yeah this is fascinating I
hadn't heard of this company they're
quite big
I can't find this clown
across every application every team can
stay aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
or dueling databases HubSpot grow better
here I'll tell you about another one
that is kinda Niche but incredibly
fascinating and then I actually have a
payment story for you as well so Google
uh group black have you heard of group
black no
all right so their URL is groupblack.co
and this company what these guys are
doing is incredibly fascinating in how
they've inserted themselves so I believe
they call themselves a media Collective
an accelerator but here's the
opportunity so in 2020 and 2021 I feel
like you hate these sorts of things
media accelerator and Collective I feel
like if I just told you hey hey man I
got a medium Collective and accelera I
want to tell you about you'd be like oh
God yeah I I don't like the language
because it does sound fluffy but what
these guys are doing is way more
fascinating uh than that so basically
2020 2021 black lives matters becomes a
thing and a lot of companies advertising
companies they publicly State basically
it happened with Byron Allen is one of
the guys he's one of the most powerful
men in Hollywood he's a black guy who
owns a uh a really successful uh
production company and he's like look
it's just crazy that uh we we black
owned media companies aren't getting ad
dollars we think it's wrong that
McDonald as an advertising with black
owned companies and so uh that plus the
BLM thing a lot of the largest ad
agencies in the world like wpp and all
these other companies they collectively
said all right look we now commit and I
actually don't know the exact percentage
that uh wpp said but they basically said
we're going to give around four five six
percent of our budget to Black owned
media companies but there's a huge
with that which is there's actually not
a lot of black owned media companies or
at least there's not a lot of black
owned media companies at scale and when
I say like you know they they actually
group and one of the world's largest ad
firms they call them their clients that
they said we're going to spend at least
two percent of our ad budgets on diverse
owned media and you're like two percent
what's that you know who cares two
percent that's nothing Well it comes out
to be like across all the other media
companies something like 600 million
dollars a year and then McDonald's is
like Hey we're gonna increase our ad
spend from two percent to Black owned
media companies to five percent it's
like well you know who cares that's just
a few points that's again another like
75 million dollars a year it's like
quite substantial but again there's this
problem of there's not a lot of group uh
a lot of black owned media companies so
this company called group black they
went and talked to Procter Gamble wpp in
Republic all these huge media companies
and they go hey
commit to spending money with us and
we're going to help you deploy it and
they say uh yeah okay you know that's
like a crazy conversation I don't know
how they got that conversation now they
have 500 million dollars a year in ad
commitments from these companies but
they have a problem they don't own any
media assets and so at this point
they're out there trying to buy bustle
you know bustle the it's a it's a
women's focused media company that I
think does like 200 million dollars a
year in sales it's like one of the
bigger like new age digital companies
out there it I think they
um you know they're the size of Vice
we're finding 29 things like that group
m is now making a bid to buy bustle and
and then they're also like I've heard
rumors that they're in talks to buy Vice
and so these guys have just totally
pulled off this like amazing it's
basically a caper if you ask me but like
these up these like they're like well we
spot an opportunity a caper like you
know like a like a like it's just like
such a bold plan to be like oh you see
this opportunity you know of course like
like I'm making it sound like they're
just like these evil scheming guys I
don't think that's actually the truth
but like it is like an interesting it's
basically like a coup it feels like
where it's like oh we see this
opportunity we're going super big and
we're gonna pounce on it and so now
they're out trying to buy media
companies that could support them
spending 500 million dollars of AD
budget a year which is huge that's
substantial I don't know how much money
BuzzFeed makes but I bet you it's in
it's probably in that ballpark and so
let me know what you're saying is
they saw the demand to advertise on
black owned media companies there's like
there's not enough inventory there's not
enough Supply so let's just go buy media
companies and then turn them black by
buying them
well right I don't know I don't know
right that's what you're psycho now yeah
they're they're black owned now and so
it's like well that's what I mean that's
what's fascinating about it you know and
there's like there's Nuance to this and
I don't entirely understand everything
they're doing obviously but that's
exactly what it sounds like they did and
so they're saying well let's go get some
blackout companies but before we do
let's go talk to wpp and all these other
companies and make sure that they're
really in and so oh hey look uh and so
they go to Blackstone or some other
private Equity Firm they go hey look we
have 500 million dollars of commitments
partner with us to go and buy these five
media companies and it's like a
guarantee that we're gonna have
increased Revenue okay okay I know I
understand why you love this so much how
fascinating is that if they could pull
this off so they're in deep talks this
is according to axios they're in deep
talks to buy bustle which was going to
go public they're in talks to buy a few
other media companies and it's just like
crazy
is up for grabs
fella
I'm already Brown I'm halfway there
how fascinating is this like is this
this is this is a caper that's why now
you understand why I called it that
they're they're they're seeing
opportunity and and I applaud I I
they're pouncing on it I think it's
incredibly fascinating I don't know a
whole lot about this but I have heard
that there's a version of this which is
like
um a certain percentage of like
government contracts and Consulting gigs
have to go to minority owned businesses
and so there's a whole industry of
basically like uh middlemen so they go
and they win the bid and then they just
subcontracted out to the company there's
no they themselves don't have like the
um company that goes and does the thing
they just go win the bids and they're
like yep because they fit like a
demographic yeah they're like oh like
and I think Magic Johnson does this the
basketball player I think I think I had
heard this is like part of like kind of
one of his like business uh strategies
or like you know something that's helped
his business do well which is that like
he wins all these bids because they're
one of the few you know minority uh LED
businesses and then he doesn't actually
it's like wow I didn't know he has a
construction company he's like no he
doesn't he just then Farms out the
construction to a subcontractor who does
the construction and they keep their
their Vig and I was like oh that's also
really you know smart but you know a
cynical person would would look at
differently
dude it's fascinating and I read about
this and a friend who had talked to them
told me about it and I was like oh that
sounds pretty skeezy and then I started
thinking about it and I'm like no that's
not skeezy at all like they're just
trying to get theirs and they are
playing by the rules of the game and
like if you do believe there's
injustices they're out there making it
right you know they're getting theirs so
I I applaud them uh and so I think it's
really interesting it's just if they're
able to pull this off it will be very
fascinating to me all right I gave you a
dutchie now let me give you a quickie so
here's the here's a quick one have you
seen the Kia car Rebrand
it looks like KW it's supposed to be KN
but it looks like KW or something
k-i-a but it looks like k n uh oh it's
it's supposed it's not supposed to be KN
no that's the problem it looks like km
and it's supposed to just be k-i-a but
the I and the a are like joined and kind
of like slanted whatever yeah it's
horrible put the picture on screen so uh
uh this guy
um Ashwin we've talked about it before
schwinnebago his his his handle on
Twitter he tweets out he goes the Keel
logo is so unreadable that at least 30
000 people a month are now searching for
KN car ever since it debuted and you
could go see search volume go from like
flat for KN car to like pretty
significant now and um and so I have a
friend who uh I met recently that
is I'm gonna get him on the podcast
we're gonna do an episode with him but
he is a master of these like internet
arbitrages and he previously had done
one like this and somebody and we were
slacking about it and they go oh my God
this is exactly the type of Arbitrage
you would do he goes That's right up my
alley and he and I go so what would you
actually do with this information
because most people are just going to
make fun of oh the logo sucks haha move
on and he's like so he's done this
before so when I when I was talking to
him I was like oh you're super
successful now how did you get like
wealthy for the first time in the first
place like what is the first successful
thing you did he goes
it's kind of embarrassing but like you
know back in the day I tried a bunch of
stuff that wasn't working and then I
just like I went to um paradisepoker.com
I wanted to play poker and I misspelled
Paradise I didn't know how I was
supposed to a pair of dice as a pair of
dice or the ass like what is it he's
like I realized that I went to the wrong
one I just went to like a dead page and
he's like that's crazy I bet a lot of
people misspelled this so he's like I
just bought Paradise poker instead of
paradise poker and he's like yeah that's
all I did and he's like so then I had
this website that was getting a bunch of
free traffic from Google uh how much
traffic Google before Google would
autocorrect and um he's like so I got a
bunch of and so he's like I became one
of the number one Affiliates for
Paradise poker uh because he's like so
that's how I made my first start I was
like a kid and I was making you know
like tens of thousands of dollars a
month just off this like typo basically
and then he did this many many times I'm
gonna have him come on and tell the full
story but he did one where Tesla was
doing a um
uh referral program where like if like
five people bought a a Tesla you from
your code you would get a free Tesla
Roadster which is like their hundred
thousand hundred twenty thousand dollar
car
and he's like
challenge accepted and he like built a
site that would immediately became like
the top ranking like Tesla like whatever
like blog or I don't even know what he
did I think what he did yeah I think he
did one with like that he ended up
getting he's like I gotta Tesla Roadster
then I you know every day I would like
earn a new Tesla Roadster it's like hey
Dad you want to test the Roadster okay
you get the next one I got my brother
one and I got another one then my friend
got one he's like Tesla shut down the
whole program I had to stop the entire
marketing program that they had been
pushing because like within a month I
had like pillaged it and it was like
winning too many free Tesla roadsters he
goes no way uh he's like I was like what
else give me more he just has like this
endless supply he's like yeah like
haven't paid for Uber in like years I
was like what
you know like back when Uber had their
like you know referral program I um I
just built a website that was like
comparing Lyft versus Uber like like
fare estimator it's like I built a fair
estimator that would estimate what does
it cost to take an Uber versus Lyft
right now and um from your destination
he's like so then and then I would just
get Lyft credits or Uber credits he's
like so you know I have like
millions in Uber credits from this site
we have to get this guy on just to talk
about all these stories he's amazing um
so so then I asked him I go what would
you like what would you actually do with
this KN thing because I don't really
understand how these work and like I
only understand the high level and as he
said he goes well I would go to someone
in Fleet Sales at Kia at a Kia
dealership and I would make them a deal
that if I send them leads I want to cut
of the sales he's like then I would just
then I would start ranking for all their
newest cars like KN tell you ride like
instead of Kia Telluride KN tell your
ride 2023 KN this k n that and I would
just spring for each of the cars
individually and um and then I would
basically be capturing their intent that
you know this person wants is interested
in buying a car and I would sell that
lead uh to one of the the Fleet Sales
people he goes the only problem is that
Google's autocorrect now is um
is much better and so you would need to
find the like terms where it's not being
autocorrected which like you know
whittles down the opportunity here but I
was like awesome whose brains are wired
like this and uh it's kind of incredible
to me it's not a skill set I've ever had
am I friends with this guy no
damn yeah we gotta have them on I'm
interested to hear all these things all
these schemes yeah it's one of those
things though that I'm like uh you know
we've had these situations where we have
a dinner with somebody and the
conversation is amazing you're like God
I wish I could have just pushed record
this would have been a top five podcast
episode ever where'd you meet them and
then we invite them on and uh and then
they're like
they like forget all their stories
they're like they like you know very
very Bland and you're like dude come on
like you know say the good things that
you told me before and like that's my
only fear is it was so good that I want
the Pod to be equal to that I don't want
any slippage from that company how'd you
meet him uh well that's part of the
story that I'll tell when he comes on I
can't tell that part right now
um so that's part of the story
yeah I've got one for you have you heard
of this guy named uh Jared isaacman does
that ring a bell never
all right it's my belly of the week
[Music]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool a billion dollars
all right so he's 39 years old have you
heard of shift four payments no
all right so shift for four payments
it's basically like square but less
known uh so this guy he started it when
he was 16 he dropped out of high school
and he worked at a payment processor
Processing Company and it took like a
month for someone to get a new credit
card he said getting a new credit card
back then was like getting a mortgage to
apply through all this paperwork and
he's like that's kind of nonsense so at
16 years old he convinced his grandpa to
give him ten thousand dollars and he
goes and he starts a credit card
processing to get the reader or to get a
card
to uh sorry if you are if you own a
restaurant right or if you don't own a a
sandwich shop and you say oh I want to
be able to like collect credit card
payments it was like getting a mortgage
it was it was it was very challenging
and they didn't really help you set it
up and it just was cumbersome but he
said oh I can make this way better so at
16 he got ten thousand dollar loan and
he starts building this business where
he gives people their credit card
processing with just one or two pages of
an application and one or two days wait
and then he gives you the the hardware
for free and so it's just he just takes
a small cut of all the dollars that go
through it and he builds this company
doing that bootstraps it up to like the
point where he they're creating uh
they're processing like a billion
dollars plus of Revenue uh and so he
builds this big thing it's called shift
four payments originally it was called
United Bank card he started it in
Pennsylvania he was pretty low-key but
he bootstrapped it for 15 years and sold
53 of the company where he was able to
make like 250 million dollars at a very
young age and uh eventually he takes the
company public it's public now and now
he's worth like 1.5 billion dollars at
the age of 39. very few people talk
about him so that in itself is amazing
but here's where things get really
interesting when he was around 26 the
company's like 10 years old he's making
some money he's trying to blow off steam
so he gets really into taking flying
lessons and so he takes flying lessons
for like two years and after two years
he gets so into it that he says I want
to try and set the world record for the
fastest around the world flight in a
light jet so basically from New Jersey
to Alaska in 61 hours he does it and
that's like a really big deal and he
raises a hundred thousand dollars in
charity for it and it's like this really
big amazing thing and so clearly this
guy Isaac he's got this like personality
of like I go all in on stuff so he gets
into a hobby and he like makes it into
like a real thing but at the age of 28
he starts or sorry at the age of 26 he
steps it up a notch and so he actually
forms a crew of people who start doing
um uh like shows so you know like uh
Fourth of July you see like an aircraft
or like a like a like a flying I don't
know what they call it what do they call
those things yeah like an air show like
an air show like he forms a group of
people that are doing like uh acrobatic
stuff for at like the Indy 500 NFL games
and he does things like that and he
turns it into like a small company and
he calls it the Black Diamond jet team
and it has a few other retired pilots
and so he starts getting embedded in
this world and so at the age of 28 he
starts this thing called wait where
what's it called it's called um draken
so it's called draken International he's
only 28 years old great and he starts so
strong
draken International is the name and
basically the premises he starts hanging
out with these retired pilots who are
part of his like a little flight show
side business and he realized that the
air uh the military at you know post
2008 they're like hurting for money
there's a financial crash and they are
basically have the way that they would
train Pilots is they would get people
who should be out in the field like
doing whatever the Air Force does they
would pull them out to go and train
other pilots and that's incredibly
inefficient and they lose money on it
and they say this isn't sustainable and
he goes I see an opportunity and so he
starts Drake and international which is
a flight instructor school for the Air
Force and so the Air Force goes to
dracon and they go hey help us train our
pilots and he goes out and he hires tons
of retired Pilots uh retired Air Force
people gives them a job and they now are
getting contracts but it takes like
four or five years to get their first
contract but they get their first ever
contract and it's 280 million dollars a
year or I don't know if it's actually a
year it's a 280 million dollar contract
sorry over five years and that's the Air
Force paying draken in order to go and
train all these uh pilots and at this
point this guy he owns this company
called Drake and Isaac does and they
have the world's largest private League
sorry Jared
whatever tomato tomato Jared you're
awesome regardless of your name at this
point now they own the world's largest
privately owned military uh tactical jet
aircraft so they have the largest
collection in the world and this guy
he's only 39 years old people never talk
about them and now he's doing all this
other crazy like going to space and
stuff like this just one of these guys
who goes all in on things on totally
separate Industries totally unknown
incredibly fascinating guy
wow uh that is amazing how did you find
out about this guy
uh well Michael the guy who does uh our
Tick Tock told me about him and I
thought it was crazy fascinating and I
just wrote a Forbes article about him
and I thought he was crazy interesting I
think he's based out of like PA like and
so four they basically do like the
credit card processing I think for like
Little Caesars and like Arby's so it's
not like right they're not like the
sexiest thing but they kind of kill it
it was bootstrapped and he's just
incredibly fascinating guy so when I
read about this person I was like how is
this how is this guy not more well known
yeah that's amazing there's a lot of
people that are like this like for every
Elon there's like you know we had Brian
Johnson on that episode I think will
have come out by the time this comes out
Brian Johnson is very Elon muskie
a lot of musk in them right like that
guy that guy's got a lot of musk in him
and you you find this where like the
number one person
is like you know super well known
but then there are like 10 other people
that are very very similar that are
completely under the radar and my
favorite move is I go buddy up to those
guys because I'm like oh wow you're
amazing but also you're not inundated
with people trying to get your time and
attention and um and I find you
fascinating so you know I wanna I wanna
hang with you oh and and it's way easier
to network with that person than
continuing to just email Mark Cuban you
know on Loop or email Elon Musk or
whoever trying to get their attention
and tweet at them and you know be like
notice me you know notice me please
dude and I've met a few of these people
there's this other guy uh Greg Mercer
who I'm friends with in in Austin he
started a jungle Scout there's a few of
these guys that I've met and they have
this energy that is another one is um
Brett Adcock who started Archer it's
like the flying car company before that
he started uh veteri which is like a job
board basically that he sold for 100
million dollars his next company that
they're making robots and I've met some
of these people and there's a few
commonalities that they have one they're
incredibly logical but two they're very
emotional in the sense of like
why are you doing this and they'll say
because it's awesome because this is so
cool like they just like although
they're logical of like well I'm just
going to call this person they're gonna
tell me X Y and Z then I'm gonna go and
like deploy this much money and like
maybe by year four I think we'll figure
it out but if it doesn't work that's
okay because then we'll do this this and
this so like they're pretty logical but
they also balance this incredible amount
of contagious enthusiasm whenever I'm
around them I just feel like good about
myself I'm like oh you just make this
sound so easy and they're like well it
is pretty straightforward you just do
this this and I just I'm going to take a
lot of risk but these people like are
incredibly
you leave them feeling hyped and uh I
don't think if I hung out with Elon
I don't think I would feel hyped when I
left him but there's these other guys
that are arguably as smart maybe
slightly less successful but still Uber
successful but I leave them and I feel
like oh you're you're quite relatable
and I've like caught your content your
your enthusiasm and so I love these
types of people
yeah that's a I think that's a good good
description of it you know like that um
they call it the midwit meme
uh what's that it's that Meme where
there's a curve and there's like the
it's hard to describe a meme that's like
a visual but like okay it's like a bell
curve and on one side is like the ogre
and on the other side is like the Jedi
genius and in the middle is the stressed
out anxious guy with like a vein
bursting through his forehead oh yeah
and basically it's like you know there's
a few you know and then it's almost like
what's that what is the thought process
and so like you know for in this case it
would be like the idiots like rockets
are cool or like you know jets are
awesome and the other guy the Jedi's
like jets are awesome and then the
middle guy is like you know but giving
getting government contracts is really
hard and this is like you know like a
thousand word spiel about why it's a
good idea and a bad idea and it's like
all the pros and cons jumbled up
together it's over analysis right and
I've actually come to believe I was
gonna make this kind of a bigger video
but I'll say it here and I'll flesh it
out later
I think most like most of Life comes
down to that midwit Meme that midwitme
might be the most insightful meme I've
ever seen in my life uh
so much you know that's like for example
let's say let's just break it down into
something non-business
let's let's pretend you're in a fight
with your wife and a fight with your
wife
um
you could you know the middle guy the
stressor vein busting out the forehead
type of dude is basically like
you know but she said this and she
always does this and yeah I I did say
that but what I really meant was right
it's like this whole thing trying to be
right about a situation
and then the Jedi and the idiot which
will just be like yeah but you know I
love her it's okay right like and they
they move on and they don't they don't
fuss with any of the BS that the guy in
the mid the Midway in the middle does
and um
and I think that all everything is like
that everywhere I walk in life I'm just
seeing the midwit meme I'm like you know
you know I just see it in business I see
it in relationships I see it in like
parenting I see it in my kids like my
kids are like this so I'm like oh yeah
they figured it out like dogs and kids
have it figured out they understand
they're like more like the Jedi and the
or the ogre in either case like yeah
they don't have it fully formed but they
understand like this is fun I'm gonna do
this and have I'm gonna be playful and
smile and laugh and it's not that
serious right like and that's how
I think most adults end up converging on
that middle of the Bell the bell curve
where they're over analyzing everything
and thinking through all this and
you really just want to be the Jedi you
just want to be like he's like this is
awesome or
um you know we need to like we need to
do this right or um you know like I'll
figure it out right like there are
certain like three word kill shots you
have when you're when you're operating
like the Jedi and um and that's what
that's more how you want to be
do you remember boosted skateboards ever
tell you about when I hung out with him
no
so years ago do you remember boosted
skateboard it's like a skateboard that
was motorized it was like before all the
scooters and stuff so it was like a
pretty big deal and uh I remember I met
the guy who founded it one time so
boosted skateboard it's a skateboard
that goes like 30 miles an hour and I
met the guy who started it and I was
asking about his background and I
believe he like worked in NASA and like
these like really big hard problems and
he was like telling me all about his
background then he was telling me all
about the boosted skateboards and like
the science behind it and the mechanics
behind it and how it's so uh interesting
and it's actually way more Technical and
then I remember saying like yeah but
like do you skateboard he goes no I
didn't until I got into this and I was
like so you know like why'd you leave
like NASA to do this and he's like
because like a fast skateboard is
awesome like he just said like
because it's because it's badass or
something like that I was like oh yeah
yeah you got a good point yeah yeah
you're correct it is it is in fact
awesome and I remember he said that to
me and I was like
that is just the best answer that is the
best answer of like having a guy like
telling me all the technical aspects of
something and and like how it actually
means this this and this and but then
just his reason for why he's even
started out in the first place wasn't
passion it wasn't anything else or was
it to make money it was just because
it's dope and I remember thinking you're
my hero
yeah if you look at what like the stuff
that Elon does I think it's very similar
right it's like
um you know
whether it's like the need-based one
where it's like yeah we're gonna need
another planet
right like yeah we'll use this one this
one will be done we're gonna need
another one right that's like the the
just for like you know a SpaceX type of
company or it's like
um
yo because it'd be awesome to like go to
Mars so I'm gonna like I'm gonna try to
do that
period it's just the best end of end of
reasoning end of justification end of
analysis right like you could just start
with that or it's like same thing with
electric cars it's like
um yeah like because your car should be
electric it's better for the environment
period not like oh do you know no no car
company's been started in 100 years and
Manufacturing is totally different than
software it's a completely different
ball game and you know financing is
gonna be tough and then you know the
batteries are it's like yeah you could
analyze everything but like at the end
of the day and same thing with like you
know as much as I find Elon obnoxious I
think he truly does do the midwit meme
where he's like
um you know Twitter it's like
Twitter should be awesome
and it's not like that's basically his
thing it's like Twitter's awesome in
spite of everything being bad about it
right like they're doing dumb things but
like Twitter's kind of awesome even
still Twitter should be really awesome
dude the best example of this is like
when he was talking about like uh I
don't remember exactly but it was like
the his SpaceX and like the rockets and
like wait a minute so you're telling me
that it's not gonna like fall from a
parachute it's literally gonna go up and
just right back down he's like you know
it's almost like why he's like oh it's
cheaper yeah we need to be able to reuse
them
yeah he's like we you know we can't just
like have this land in the ocean like we
gotta like go and reuse it so we're just
gonna have it go up and then just come
right back down to where it is and we'll
we'll figure out how to do it it can be
done right okay yeah if it can be done
then then we'll do it yeah right like I
remember he says that like if it's not
against the laws of physics
then we go for it if it's against a lot
of physics we don't do it
I thought that was great but uh anyway
uh this guy uh the booster guide was
interesting but yeah this what's his
name Jared Isaacs and we call him Isaac
my boy Isaac this guy's awesome I love
Jared Isaac man not Isaac's son so I'm
dude Jared if this gets to you I hope it
does I'm sorry I I you know a rose
biting another name is that like the
phrase it doesn't matter what I'll call
you sir whatever you want to be called
You're a great in my book uh we have we
got to get this guy in the Pod right
he's awesome but Ben's back Ben can you
say why you were gone I had twins or I
did not my wife had twins
we are pregnant you um you you I
remember the day after we finished
recording you're like you could just see
it on your face like what happens like
we just had the ultrasound found out
it's Twins and like the implications of
it being two not one I mean that is
that's a pretty big uh uh fun but also
crazy Blind Side and uh I remember you
were wearing it on your face that day
how does it feel now
good yeah I felt like I just seen a
ghost uh that day
um but it had and you know it's funny I
was at a conference that Sam was also at
and uh Steph Smith comes up to me and
it's like hey you're having twins I just
met this other guy who at this
conference who's having twins and you
should go talk to him so I wouldn't talk
to him and I was like Yeah man so what's
it like having twins and when I had my
first kid anytime you'd ask someone
what's it like you know having a kid
they'd be like oh it's a lot of work but
it's great so Steph introduces me to
this guy and I'm like hey man what's it
like having twins and he goes it's
horrible like you're gonna die it's so
much work like I don't know how you're
gonna make it through I was like oh this
guy's kind of crazy I found it's a theme
I've talked to multiple people and
they've all been like buckle up it's not
good uh
you you should dread it it's gonna be
awful and uh my review after uh like a
week and a half of having twins is uh
not that bad
all right
for anyone out there who's got my twins
there you go at least the first few
weeks not that bad Sam what does your
thing say only money what does that say
oh It's Only Money all right what's that
tell me the story I got nothing I bought
it you know that's just I think that's a
good life's motto when you lose a bunch
of money it's only money and also when
we think about it all the time it's not
that important but let me ask you guys a
quick question
would you ever consider not naming your
child right away
like getting to know the baby over six
or 12 months and then naming them
you know it's like if um
if I was the California government and
then somebody commits a crime here but
then they leave and they go to you know
um China it's like would you consider
going and getting them it's like it's
not my jurisdiction that's what's like
with with important kids decisions it's
not my jurisdiction if I went to my wife
and I was like yo we're gonna do
something crazy she's like uh no thank
you uh next you know you noted uh we
will be moving on now dude I had a
friend who didn't name his he named his
child legally baby and on the child's
one year birthday they named her and I
at first I was like man I think that's
crazy just be normal you know just do
somehow how did they how did they
eventually name her
so they basically had three envelopes
with names that they liked and they laid
them out and they let her crawl to one
and that's what they named her the one
that she crawled to and I was like
that's when they explained to me what
they're gonna do I was like that's just
crazy why would you ever do that uh and
after a while I realized that's actually
fantastic that's that's the way to go uh
you know it's kind of weird to name
something and I've met another parent
that renamed the child after six months
and they're like he just didn't feel
like a George we're gonna call him bill
or something like that and I actually
think that's 100 the right way to do
things yeah I think it's pretty common I
think my mom was named something else
and then changed it uh after like
whatever they changed after a little bit
of time my wife's sister same thing
after six months they changed her name
she was like having dreams and being
like her name's not that that's not what
it's supposed to be she wouldn't change
her name yeah it's kind of crazy
I think it's cool my naming philosophy I
have come around to a new naming
philosophy which is this it's it's a
hack uh for my we we had a boy and a
girl for the girl we gave her my mom's
middle name
and when we told my mom
within like five minutes her reaction
was well I'm flying out next week like
if you need me to stay up past midnight
multiple days I'm willing to do it like
you could tell there's like a little
extra investment of course she's already
invested in her grandkids right but like
when it was named after her there's like
a little extra investment that like
clicked on in her brain and when you
name them things that are not your
parents or grandparents names you're
just like leaving money on the table so
that's it it's hilarious just name them
after parents and grandparents and get
that extra help that's right I think
that's that's what happens when you read
How to Win Friends and Influence People
while you're uh you know you're at the
hospital
baller
all right that's the episode see ya
[Music]